[Music]
danielle
is in tampa florida hi danielle how are
you
hi mr randy thank you very much for
taking my call sure what's up
um i'm in a position where
i'm thinking about selling my house my
son's father and i
live together and it's not the best
situation
um your blinds.com advice actually was
pretty spot on
as far as our situation goes um i've
connected with one of your elps and
i'm just really torn because i love my
home and i love my neighborhood but
i just want to be able to pay my debt
off and provide better for my son
okay uh so you own the home with
your boyfriend or no sir
it's just me you own it yeah
okay um when is he leaving
uh that's a great question well i'll
give you the answer
tonight i can hear it no no i can hear
it in your voice
you sound really afraid to me
yeah well i'm trying to talk to you
outside and he's actually standing next
to me because she can't go inside
sir um i have about 16 000 worth his
worth of debt
um it includes a car a credit card some
medical debt from the birth of our son
that i get no helpless yeah um
my home your elt said that i could
potentially walk away with about 88
000. yeah so i could reasonably take all
that off i could
set my son up and myself up in a nice
townhome or a reasonable townhome in a
nice area
good schools you have shot all this out
what is your income
uh i just got a promotion at my job i've
been there about 10 years
um i don't quite know what it works out
to be but it's 21 an hour i believe it's
like 44.
okay how old are you
i'll be 32 this monster how old's your
baby
eight months
[Music]
okay um i don't know if you need to sell
your house or not
you may that's possible but that's not
your problem today is it
yes sir yeah okay do you have family in
the area okay
i do um my mom passed away about two
years ago unfortunately so
um brothers and oh you're do you have
dad
a father and brothers in the area
yes i am my grandma my aunt who would
have room for me and charlie
my son okay um you need to get in the
car
and go to your dad's house when you hang
up the phone
i can't do that i've tried that early
why can't you do that
do i need to call the police for you
no sir we've already gone through that
uh well i'm about to go through it again
where are you danielle are you outside
your house right now
yes i am you are okay do you have car
keys where's charlie where's your
where's your son
in his father's house in front of my car
all right you need to uh when you hang
up you need to call the police you need
to call your father
and you need to get you and your son
away from this guy do you hear me
do you understand
this is not going to work otherwise
honey this is not a house problem and
it's not a debt problem
you and your son are in danger
do you understand me
hello yes sir i'm sorry
where'd you go sir can you hear me
yeah i can where are you okay okay i'm
sorry did you hear what i said or were
you
distracted yes i did sir no i heard you
okay
so are you going to sit there in the
middle of the sewage or are you going to
fix it
i want to fix it that's why i want to
tell my home and i just want to go no no
honey we don't need to call a realtor we
need to
get the boyfriend out of the house and
that's going to involve the police and
or your father and your brothers
he needs to leave it's your house
and you're afraid you understand that
this is wrong right
yes sir okay this is this is you're
you're not the crazy one
i'm talking to the same one you know
what a lot of training feels like that
yeah i know all right i'll tell you what
we're gonna do
we're gonna put you on hold and kelly is
gonna make sure that law enforcement
gets over there okay
no sir don't you please no baby doll
i'm not gonna be i'm i'm not listening i
love you and that baby
do what i just needed to know if i
should feel like how to not
[Music]
you're in a horrible situation and you
have to make the moves to get away from
it
okay and part of part of the type of
situation that you are
in is that his part of his psychological
job is he has convinced you that you're
not able to operate without him
and i'm convinced the only way you're
ever going to be able to operate is
without him
you understand me yes sir okay
you listen you are worth
being okay it's worth being okay for
your kid
it's worth being okay it's your freaking
house
he's trespassing we're gonna remove
the trespasser it has to happen
okay you have to get away from this guy
anyone who calls a national radio show
and is in this kind of distress tells me
that there's serious stuff going on
inside your walls
you understand and then once he's clear
we're going to put you with one of our
counselors free
i'm not going to charge you a dime and
we're going to walk with you and
then we can start making decisions about
your finances
but you don't have a financial problem
you need a boyfriend ectomy
[Laughter]
and it's happening today darling
it's happening today do you understand
yes sir today and danielle if you feel
like you need
you and your son to be somewhere safe
then i would get out of the house as
well
removing him may not well not you know
but i mean
after he's gone you can make this
determination you may need to go to
local law enforcement but
you know get a restraining order you can
do whatever you need to do at that point
but you and the baby need to get out of
there
until he's gone and then you need to get
someone to remove him
and it's that simple so
um that's what you have to do and then
you can begin to have a conversation
uh in some form of sanity because the
situation you are in right now is insane
it's an insane situation you're not
insane but the situation's crazy girl
thank you sir thank you hey we love you
you hold on a second kelly's gonna pick
up okay
and we're gonna make sure you get taken
care of you weren't scheduled to be
involved in the show yesterday but you
got involved behind the scenes a little
bit
yeah for those of you that were not
around yesterday for whatever reason i
don't usually tell you what yesterday is
but all that but this is
the time we're gonna stop and do that um
we had a young lady
call in with rachel and i on the air
that um
became apparent during the call that she
was uh
a victim of domestic violence which i
don't even like
saying that that way because it sounds
so antiseptic
she was a victim of her boyfriend
beating the crap out of her
is a better way of saying the truth and
we determined that and uh then uh while
we were on the call we determined he was
in the room that he had walked in and
was not happy
and so um uh
it went from a financial question to a
question of her safety and her child's
safety and so forth on the air
live it's pretty wicked weird and wild
but um walk her through that a little
bit
and um john just happened to
walk by the studio and stepped in and uh
i put her on hold and he does a lot has
done a lot of
uh trauma and uh crisis uh
intervention type counseling over the
years and so
um trained in that but also experienced
in that so we got a you got on the phone
with her and
um we were able to get the uh the police
over there very quickly and
uh the young man is sitting where he
should be now in a cage
um which is where people like that
belong um
and so i think they call that a jail but
i called it a cage
um very simple either one is very simple
either one's fine with me but they're
both
similar situation here this is where
this little guy needs to be
and uh so that was pretty wild
discussion you were having in there off
air
yeah i i noticed at one point i didn't
know who would who was in there
you know you kind of zone out and lock
try to lock
in in face to face you lock eyes but in
those situations you lock hearts with
somebody
and then i noticed you'd come in there
after a while but yet it was intense
mainly because it was live it was
happening live and she was
not it wasn't philosophically unsafe she
was unsafe now
and somebody else had her kid and then
you've got a mom who needs to protect
herself
but i'm not gonna leave my baby
unprotected
and now you've got a messy situation and
um
whenever i show up to something like
that i'm always looking at escalation
trends is this thing slowing down are
people separating and they just yelling
at each other or is it moving up and
this one moved up real rapidly
and um luckily the police department
there was super responsive and they
showed up
and i'm grateful to them and at the end
of the day i mean we're talking to a
really brave
brave young woman brave new mom and
she's got a hard row ahead of her but
yeah things got pretty dicey there for a
minute
yeah and that's not that's not us
hollywoodizing this thing no
it got pretty nice it was it was very
real yeah
and uh he's a violent dude and uh so
the uh yeah of course
so the end of the story is she's safe
her family's around her
and of course we're gonna we've plugged
her in with financial counseling she
does have some
crisis financial situation as well and
got us some resources there some
domestic violence really was not even on
the table for discussion yesterday
so but our our team is rallying around
here we're plugging her in with
counselors not
of course no charge and we're just going
to walk with her and make sure she gets
gets her life uh changed in a different
direction because it sure was going down
the toilet pretty fast
we did we connected her some um domestic
violence resources there in tampa too so
that
she can have a local community that can
be hands-on there yeah and
yeah so so she's safe and good for those
of you who are listening a lot of you
been
you know emailing us and worried and so
forth and
so we thought we would give you guys a
bit of an update and you know it's odd
you and i were talking i think it was
last week on the air
about this correlation between um
extreme control over money issues and
domestic violence
that there's a correlation between that
because there's this where
uh where a husband or a boyfriend it
will not let you pick the cereal
at the grocery store you can't go
grocery shopping by yourself you can't
buy detergent you can't do anything
without his approval on every little
nuanced thing where there's that level
of weird
toxic control over a lady
a woman uh with the money
it's it's a high statistical indicator
that he's probably hitting her
it's just about power right and i'll
take that power over i can get it
yeah it's about power and control and
boy you know that was going on yesterday
and you could smell it in the air so i
put her on the air
air it was um it didn't take a genius to
figure out what was to you know to
figure out what i was dealing with what
we're going into there but
you know i think the the thing that um
you can't get away from on the positive
side
or the negative side of toxic toxic
behaviors
is that um our behaviors is that
personal finance
is 80 behavior it's only 20 head
knowledge so the chances of you being in
a
relationship that are that dysfunctional
and being wealthy
yeah uh becoming wealthy in a
dysfunctional setting is just
almost impossible right because these
things don't live in one nice little
compartment over here
uh and then not bleed over or not not
bad bad metaphor but don't don't reach
over into the other areas of your life
i mean you can't be a punching bag in
one area of your life and then suddenly
be prosperous and healthy and
winning at your career and winning at
your wealth building and that kind of
thing they just don't it's not
we can't compartmentalize that tight
right and one of the challenge with
relational abuse of any kind is
you accept that as a given you accept
that as
well some days are good days
occasionally he'll come and cry and say
and he's sorry
and it's going to be okay and so you
start trying to solve
that inner chaos at the margins you
start trying to think of well maybe i
can get a better interest rate or maybe
i should trade my car in or it's
probably my job
and you're and you distance yourself
from this core
nuclear reactor issue that is hey you're
not safe
your baby's not safe and this thing just
escalates this way right so
um to anyone the decisions you make on
the money on the fringes
to avoid the nuclear reactor at the
center are never good decisions they're
not
because you're making them out of chaos
right well and you're making them uh
to uh in order to mask that's right and
in order instead of dealing with
with the core issues and so you know
larry burkett used to say debt is not
the problem it's the symptom
there you go and so it's a symptom of a
behavior
well i heard you say something yesterday
through the window that i think's worth
reiterating
you listened to her and you said hey hon
you are
worth being saved you're worth more than
this
and so anybody listening was in any sort
of
abusive situation exhale and drop your
shoulders for a second
and look up in the rearview mirror if
you're driving and look in the mirror at
your house
you're worth being safe